welcome back to cbs this morning we're
going to start the hour with the new
mayor of the nation's most heavily
populated city his name is eric adams he
was sworn in as mayor of new york city
just five days and counting and like
many leaders across the country he's
facing an unprecedented spike in covet
19 cases there have been more than 3.4
million new cases nationwide in the last
seven days yikes and here in new york
city hospitalizations have topped 5 000
a day for the first time since spring of
2020 the numbers are not good throughout
the pandemic the city is frequently
served as a warning to the rest of the
country about what's to come now eric
adams is the only second black mayor of
new york city he also previously served
as captain in the nypd and he joins us
as you see at the table
liven in color you did your covet
testing we're following all the
protocols you passed which is why you're
sitting at the table we welcome you
thank you it was good to be here you
know on election on the night i was
sworn in i had a picture of my mom i was
holding in my hands she transitioned uh
last year in april and she symbolizes
who we are
of you know mothers always say to me you
know baby you're going to be born in
dark places you're going to be in dark
places you need to turn them into not
burials but planting that's what we are
as new yorkers and americans we're going
to we're going to survive this are we
because listen mr mayor when we walk
around the city and you see people lined
up in the coveted lines i wonder what
you think when people are sitting there
for two three hours at a time despite
the spike you're saying the city is
going to remain open you want people to
go back to work you want people to go
back to school why do you feel so
confident about that when the numbers
look so bleak and so scary well because
we've been through crisis before i don't
care if it's pearl harbor if the great
depression if they're seeing our two
buildings attacked during 9 11. but
remember 9 12 we got up
and we continue to survive don't see
ourselves in the crisis you see yourself
past the crisis that negative energy in
our country is really destroying our
children it's destroying each other
we're tired of being prisoners to covey
so let's be smart let's do the social
distancing let's weigh our mass get
vaccinated and take the booster shot and
then let's make sure we test we're going
to make sure we put a million point five
tests in our schools so we can identify
the child that has coveted and ensure
that the rest of the classroom is not
infected at the same time
now i understand uh we are survivors but
we also adjust and shouldn't we be
adjusting when it comes to our kids i
mean i get it we want them back to
school as well but should we be thinking
about remote learning and how to improve
that moving forward just in case um our
kids are sitting at home like they were
last year because you've made it clear
you want them in school yeah to nature
that's plan b that's plan b we have a
plan you have a plan b right but we're
clearing the plan a and why aren't we
clearing the plan a the safest place for
a child is in school little johnny's not
in school he's not in his room he's in
the streets you know he doesn't have his
mask on and then you go to those
communities where they don't have
high-speed broadband wi-fi where they
can't go online and get the education
they they need over 100 000 children are
homeless
they don't have the same resources now
if you're able to say i have a little
room for my little son or daughter right
where they have the computer technology
i'm there to support you then that's
fine but that's that's not new york
particularly in non-english-speaking
communities i hear you on that new york
gets a lot of attention nationally uh
particularly from republicans who say
it's a testing ground for democratic
ideas and if you look at our big cities
new york uh la san francisco the i the
ideas are not working and this brings us
to crime uh you've got some double-digit
increases in some some significant areas
and there's a feeling among new yorkers
i i feel it as a new yorker and i hear
from other people that the city is not
as safe as it was
you're new to this you just started but
you got a deep background in law
enforcement when are we going to see
details on this safe new york plan and
and what are you expecting to make this
city
livable the way it once was well i'll
say i'm new to this but i'm true to this
okay
you know that i've been doing this for a
while and i was clear on the campaign
trail i said new yorkers it is gangs and
guns every time you see a shooting read
the next sentence gang related so what
did we do yesterday with d.a
eric gonzalez he showed the graph he
brought down three gang crews violent
gang crews and what happened shootings
dropped he brought down a gang crew
yesterday that was known for all of the
violence in certain parts of brooklyn we
have to go after the gangs
everybody agrees you should go after
serious violent crime that's not
controversial but the you know the
manhattan d.a made comments yesterday
about not going after
smaller offenses uh fair beating
resisting arrest there were a couple
that he listed and that's controversial
uh do you think that stopping big crime
begins by going after smaller crime yes
i do but also i know
d.a bragg i i respect him he's a great
prosecutor a former u.s attorney and
here's what i believe in my plan as i
speak with them at the precinct level
someone comes in for a a petty theft
right at the precinct level you identify
that they have a mental health issue
instead of locking them up let's defer
prosecution let's have a local community
based organization that deals with
mental health illnesses handle it right
at the precinct that's the coordination
we need there's no reason to put someone
a mental health illness in rikers island
but that's a revolving door let's give
them the services they need so we can
prevent them from going into the dwayne
reed ceiling again can we talk about
stop and frisk because you seem to be
very open to stop and frisk you know
many people believe that it's a racist
policy uh mayor bloomberg actually
apologized for stop and frisk and i've
heard you say you're open to it as long
as it can be done properly how do you do
stop and frisk properly without
targeting black and brown people yeah so
that's such an important question we
talk about this often but it never
really settles in on people and
bloomberg apologized for the abuse
a misuse of a tool is a weapon
we weaponize a tool so you call someone
gail and you state that there's a man in
front of my house they put a gun in his
waistband if that police officer can't
go and investigate that crime ask that
person stop them question them and then
frisk them if the law if the level of
questioning reaches that then you have
taken away a valuable tool that too
that's pretty specific though mr mayor i
think a lot of people that complained
about stop and frisk was reasonable
suspicion and you can make anything
reasonably suspicious can't you yes and
that's the abuse remember when i say it
yeah use of a tool is a weapon and why
do i know that so well i testified in
federal court in the floyd versus new
york city police department the judge
wrote in her testimony
i'm ruling against the police department
basically because of eric adams
testimony 100 blacks in law enforcement
the organization i co-founded we led the
charge of the over overly abuse of stop
and frisk and how police were abusing
and policing in this city you brought in
a chief of police from the outside
sterling reputation out on long island
i know you're huddling with her
what is the timetable for a speech from
you or a detailed plan from you on on
crime uh in the city well you know i
love when people say that the timetable
was eric's timetable
right i must put together the right team
the right analysis bringing my district
attorneys my atf my federal my state and
my city lawmakers i know it's exciting
um when the media says you know give us
a date give us a date no it's my date
i'm the mayor of the city well i'm going
to do it right i'm not going to roll it
out prematurely just because people are
asking the question i'm going to roll it
out ready we have a plan in place i want
to get buy-in from my state lawmakers
right i want to get buy-in for my
district attorney attorneys and
prosecutors and i want to get buy-in
from the other law enforcement agency if
you roll it up prematurely people get
offended and you don't get to execute
your plan well as mayor of the city
you've been on the job five days and
already you're getting some criticism
you said cooks and dishwashers don't
have academic skills to sit in a corner
office did you mean it the way that it
came out because when when the headline
doesn't look so good it wasn't a great
headline right right yeah no we've been
saying low-skilled low-skilled employees
listen i was a cook
you know i was a dishwasher uh what was
the point you were making that when you
talk about closing down our city yeah
if you are a dishwasher you can't
remotely do your job and if we don't
have an accountant in an office space
coming to a restaurant occupy that space
exactly then you're not going into that
restaurant that dishwasher is not going
to have a job
can do his job right exactly and the
goal is we need to open the city so
low-wage employees are able to survive
if no one came into that restaurant when
i was paying my way through college i
would not have been able to survive and
families can't survive and that's the
message people are going to try to take
everything i say and distort it but i'm
focused i'm disciplined and i'm grinding
to bring my city back all right
no i saw your news conference yesterday
the only mayor i've ever heard guys say
okay guys i gotta bounce
mr mayor we thank you this album is
dropping you gotta bounce we appreciate
you come on back thank you thank you
never heard that before
eric adams